how's it going bros my name is babe
we're playing until dawn I love this I'm
so happy that I get to play this game
for you breaths let's just keep going
this game is amazing let's see what's
gonna happen all those emotions that my
sister's got to film one knew it he had
the motive Josh but none of us are
laughing oh come come come come why the
long faces come on it's good to get the
heart racing every now and then right
and race they did I mean any one of you
just pitter-pat pitter-pat I hope you
appreciated my little what about the
ghost no [ __ ] way that was fake too
man I call that [ __ ] see I'd call that
[ __ ] for every little stinker don't even
ask this sporty little grunt he's got no
clue he's out of his [ __ ] tree that's
really off his meds oh come on you guys
revenge is the best medicine done Mike
he's sick what come on you guys are all
gonna thank me when you guys become
internet sensations like what what oh oh
you better believe this little puppies
going viral ladies and germs I mean we
got the unrequited love we got we got
blood
I don't think there's enough hard drives
in China tip to count all the views for
gonna get you guys at Jessica's [ __ ]
dead what did you hear me
Jessica is dead we're gonna forget paddy
ah guys guys come on seriously this is
crazy you know shut up
why'd you hit her man huh what's it the
[ __ ] hit her ah what are you talking
about Ashley you piece of [ __ ] oh yeah
that's true oh I got so mad you don't
hit a girl you just don't dude dude
Chris bro I'm not your bro
yeah we're not bro say no more where are
you guys taking me locked up bro what
you can't do anything stupid before we
call police
I didn't do anything
are you serious bro goddamn murders a
lot of growing here Michael please just
listen to me man I did not hurt Jessica
just shut up
man you need to shut up Chris come on
Cochise we're partners stop don't see
what would happen if we chose the girl
in that sawsan area I'm really curious
now oh you just feel a little pain
Michael I'm sorry man I can't tell you
how sorry I am that something happened
to Jessica but I swear I swear to you I
have no idea what happened to her
so they weren't working together then um
I'm kind of pissed for a single goddamn
second after all this [ __ ] you put us
through
not [ __ ] around
Mike B is dead - can we talk about that
like you got the guts to really do
anything about it anyways hey this guy
really [ __ ] lots of shame huh I did
something I made you believe in the
world I created and I showed you parts
of yourself you are too afraid to visit
manipulate us you tricked us you hurt
your friends and you did it all while
you hid in the shadows you're a coward
Josh that's all you are
what are they doing this is so weird
I have so many thoughts going on is he
talking about this is hard to watch
oh and Chris what forget about ever
getting into Ashley's little panties
after that little [ __ ] up with the hole
I'm gonna shoot her in the head thing
she's better off with Mike over here
anyways at least he knows how to treat a
lady
it's not shoot her in the face I'm gonna
beat his head off
don't listen to him not worth it hey
Mike Mike Mike Mike Mike Mike yeah Mike
what what happened with Jess Mike you
know what happened no no I don't i got a
problem Mike I don't remember killing
Jess Christ I mean like I feel like I
would remember killing her you know
she's the song
and she's probably got like a really
tight bond
shut your [ __ ] mouth [ __ ] man
okay I'm not something what am I gonna
do oh I thought it was him that was
awkward as [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] browse browse everything's
alright stay here with this sleepover I
want to know everything's fine back
there yeah right okay
alright so the first Mysteria is sold
but we still have some missing mysteries
and some unanswered questions and we're
gonna get into those alright this is
getting pretty [ __ ] interesting yeah
no he's still clown no one is surprised
just [ __ ] dead what did you hear me
jessica is dead you were gonna [ __ ] it
back [ __ ] what happened with Jess Mike
I don't remember killing Jesse Christ
there's the guy doing the predator thing
the guy with the gas maybe he's still
trying to help us I still think that guy
is good yeah so there's a flamethrower
guy who's masks who would that be
wonder if we know who that is I wonder
why would you be carrying around a
[ __ ] flamethrower but why so yeah he
found ice because there are actually
months okay that makes sense
and that's the man that killed my candy
decided to make sense now I mean it
doesn't really make sense but I'm trying
to make sense of the story that looks
amazing look at this
that is real 4:00 in the morning we're
with Emily I don't like this girl not a
big fan
god damn flares are creepy flares are
proper creepy maybe the monsters are
like people who escaped the sanatorium
because there's obviously not any horror
alum and like a sorry unnatural elements
to this actually No
who is Billy Bates
okay well that might be a clue Billy
Pugh where are you Billy Bo I Love You
Billy Billy boo what it's this place I'm
getting tired of the mines man we've
been there for a long time let's drop
down let's go deeper damn that was
[ __ ] God
well a natural or unnatural wait what
did I just say natural or unnatural they
still are [ __ ] creepy hello it's so
dark
Oh God why do I have to be alone in this
place oh god what is this totem Oh No
it's a fortune totem well then today is
our lucky day press great we need to get
the [ __ ] out of here how about we follow
the tracks that seems like a good plan
yeah all right cool
let's just go this way then where the
creepy noises are coming from just great
oh [ __ ]
this is gonna be creepy God says oh
there was something there always missed
it what do we get again this is going to
be the way okay
whenever you see I remember that we had
a totem about oh god I almost missed oh
Jesus oh god they're [ __ ] climbing oh
that is a nasty all right oh sorry
please work please go up
Raven come on you're fine come on Emily
I don't like you but come on come on
it'd be you rest in peace
I love them well like my father
maybe the elevator his name is Sam look
at her face it's so puffy oh god oh god
I'm not moving
don't ever do that it would be so funny
if they did a jump escape while you had
snow and if you don't if a god they said
thing
then I press yeah I did that was like
last it's [ __ ] oh god this is really
intense
oh nice dude hey what about the other
guy aren't you gonna burn him now yeah
that looks safe
go right ahead Emily go go go go go
this reminds me of heavy rain the last
the last scene stay on
oh good job good job good call
oh my god yeah yeah no I like this come
on
oh that was close that was real [ __ ]
close so those are the things that go
right Jessica
whoa I'm scary
so focus the tiger in the wind this is
badass look at you and believe me crap
I'd be [ __ ] scared if I did this oh
that's not hard that's got a really
[ __ ] hurt this is so intense
huh okay let's keep going
you made it this far Emily quite
surprised you can walk but we're gonna
talk to Peter I have a good feeling
about here no oh no more Jase
I had enough quarter Ranson running
Emily you can do it can we trust her
come on sir what are you talking about I
said there's something outliers why she
relaxed it was Josh it was all jobs no
no listen to me I have tied up he can't
hurt you it was after me and it wasn't
human
hold on hold on I am trying to tell you
we were climbing up the tower and it it
fell the whole tower just fell right
into the mine whoa what my oh my god yes
so many questions mine shafts all over
running under everything when the tower
fell we ended up down I don't understand
the tower fell out of fall I was walking
down there in the mines and it was
darkening I do I have to hear this there
was Beth's head wait what yes I'm
serious
I think they fell down there oh Jesus
Christ
where's Maddie being worst part is I
don't think that Hannah died like from
the fall not right away
wait what what do you mean I don't know
I feel like she was down there like
starving to death for weeks when we were
all up here looking for her we had no
idea oh so they never actually recovered
the body is it our there was there was a
radio and I got through to someone but
then that was right when the tower
collapsed am
you made it and there's gonna be the
final boss monster who's chasing her
she's all messed up guys
Emily hey em whoa [ __ ] Josh Jess it's
not Jeff
as I remember what is it I don't know we
should check it out
come on you guys have five you just
punch it
there's so much crazy [ __ ] going on in
this place at once
is that the guy yeah sometime throw
again let me have the best dunkers I
mean you could take whoever it is
through sheer good looks and muscle and
all it just I should have the pistol
when you put it that way
that's really funny she get your own
show
not gonna shoot him no you can't okay
everybody just calm down
you mean with him on your horses I don't
take kindly to kids coming up here to
your Mountain I'm sure the Washington's
would be very surprised to hear that
Mexico let's hear about the Native
American [ __ ] guilty of something Shh
Mike there is a curse that dwells in
these mountains should any man or woman
resort to cannibalism in these woods the
spirit of the Windigo shall be unleashed
what crap
you're gonna need to find somewhere safe
amazing it might be okay okay get down
there now all of you and wait but why
for how long until dawn guys until done
ran off and left Josh when I heard
screaming why did you leave her in the
shed
your friend will already be dead great
no no yeah yeah we were just with him
I'm not gonna happen quickly on this
mountain no I'm gonna go get him you
can't go out there Chris
I'm supposed to be his best friend and I
let him down no he like you don't Chris
he let all of us down I don't care I'm
going to get him and I'll go with you
really we're actually gone it's suicide
fine the rest of you get down in the
basement be safe don't go outside again
until we're back you don't seem to
understand the magnitude of the
situation
well I'm going to get Josh on I know I'm
going to get Josh you're going to help
me do you understand yeah you might as
well just call him a [ __ ] you're my
[ __ ] and you follow me [ __ ]
Oh dad you know how to use a shotgun man
no you don't what how do you know
trust me I know Casey saw me shoot I
shot pretty well before hey Ashley
sorry about I'm trying to shoot you
before okay
she looks creepy what's a guy got to
know he just be careful you follow my
lead the [ __ ] that mean good tip bro I
don't like fire how many are there
what are these things like I mean are
they just crazy unpredictable or I mean
can you figure out what they're gonna do
adhere to some patterns like you animal
like how they've got schedules they only
hunt at night why I didn't ask
about this
oh my god it's like Jurassic Park so
technically the only characters that
have died so far is Jessica and Matty B
but we only got met it be confirmed that
he's dead and Josh now apparently
good I'm glad we went out then [ __ ]
idiot right now we gotta find Josh I can
still be out there first
you'll render you a while and then these
strips of skin off of your entire body
these miners
he keeps you alive and aware and feasts
on your organs one piece at a time
I wonder if Hannah is the one that
resorted to cannibalism that would make
sense she ate her sister to stay alive
man they really didn't do a good job
searching if they couldn't find the
[ __ ] mines Jesus Christ someone must
have known about the guy
oh [ __ ] do time to go
Babbitt I bet I have the option to shoot
him
that's interesting okay we got to be
swift here all right we got this brush
no problem no [ __ ] problem
take your time there you go nice [ __ ]
step okay come on
come on Chris
I'll be aiming yeah we are [ __ ] you
damn that thing packs up [ __ ] yeah punch
yeah hey buddy oh my god no no no no god
dammit that's so annoying
[ __ ] me I was gonna shoot the explosive
I could have easily shot come on god
damn it I wanted him to live [ __ ]
that's the point of the game you're just
gonna have to swallow it not everything
is gonna go the way you want to like
first Mike and now I thought like the
thing in the back was like explosives
and I could shoot that in because it was
the fire thing and then it took too much
time Sam what about that old guy no sign
of him I think he's got to be dead too
huh oh right
he's all the doors yeah are you sure
what are you looking for another way out
Mike I really don't think that's a good
idea we should stay put right here and
tilt on at least we're safe down here oh
yeah I'll wrapped up like a little
present with a bow on top for that thing
to tear us apart on Christmas morning
people come for us in the morning
yoga pants answer sure that is what will
happen right em yeah I mean right well
you can wait I'm leaving
Mike there's no key for the cable car
Josh he's got to have it Josh
I was dirty little tricks that's true
great great that's a good point that
[ __ ] thing got ahold of Josh and then
we're [ __ ] out of luck
yeah I don't know Mike it's possible
what's possible it may have taken him
down to the mine what I saw some
horrible stuff down there I think it's
where that thing lives and huh
I'm fine [ __ ] it I'm gonna get that key
right from that things goddamn bedroom
and then I'm gonna get us all the hell
out of here what is going on he's all
that so that old guys bag man
that guy was prepared for anything not
quite what is this place oh my god hey
what is that
I was down there is horrible
you are some of them survived but like
15 of them didn't make it Michael I'd
like to maybe focus on how we're gonna
get the [ __ ] out of here please
I'm just saying it's weird how much
crazy shits gone on a bear what's weird
is that there's a tunnel leading from
the lodge to the sanatorium see that's
how I got back here I saw this when I
was down there that's where it lives huh
what what why what me and Mitch you what
bit you the one to go nothing really
it's not okay [ __ ] it doesn't hurt
anymore really it's it's not that bad
um that thing that thing bit me why you
yes Emily at least let us check it out
Emily if the Windigo that you you could
turn into one of those things how did
they know that each other remember he
said that you can't be down here with us
what oh yeah hi you've got to go why
you're putting us all in danger
Emily you can't stay here
Mike just cool your head okay we don't
know if it works like that maybe it's
just a bite yeah guys what are you doing
I don't like her but that's the stupid
doors right
I am letting you do this voluntarily oh
no you're just making yourself feel
better about sending me to my death
since you know there's a one to go out
there ready to rip me to pieces like it
did with okay oh my god you just go go
get out of here [ __ ] [ __ ]
well okay Mike calm down she the only
sane person in this game like me this is
the safe room em it's not safe as long
as you're in it
not for us I'm really sorry I'm not
gonna shoot and shoot this map
yeah I got an email notification just
has it happen maybe would have been kind
of awesome to just blow her brains out
anything weird you guys know what to do
yeah no one leave okay it's not safe out
there
I'll be back soon why is are we
splitting up what the [ __ ] this is
getting so out of hand yeah yeah yeah
with a flamethrower dude now we don't
have a chance
it just means we've got to be tough
you've got to do this on her own
we're playing ash again
only few men have dared to hunt the
Windigo guys a little OCD I'm the only
man who has ever kept them under control
okay they grow out of cannibalism when
they have enough in four days the
Wendigo spreads will begin to possess
him it actually makes sense for the
Hannah thing then
like cramming for flesh that cannot be
sated and then the change begins the
eyes turn first they become milky and
white okay let's look out for that for
the girl then what else did we get
another clue okay they have hard armor
they feel no pain this says that because
the Wendigos are mutated from humans
when they hunt us they know how to
perfectly mimic their prey does that
mean
this is so creepy
oh no no no what what is it saying
I didn't read it
well they're both kind of it says that
let's try this if it bites you it's not
infectious it doesn't do anything
why was she knowing about it I'm sorry
what did you say so she'll be okay it
says what fine fine
Michel will shot me that fine she knew
you and this [ __ ] almost let him that's
not fair she was scared I'm the one
who's scared sorry I'm sorry I'm like I
didn't know what was going down
none of us know there's no excuse
there's no excuse I like please just try
to understand I understand the palm of
my hand [ __ ] oh [ __ ] sorry [ __ ] you got
a trophy for that [ __ ] you've got why
no one hesitated to follow not a single
bet oh that was an intense episode
they're all intense oh my god
all right we're nearing the end this is
so cool I'm loving playing this for you
bros I'm sorry that I have to end them
here this is as long as I can keep them
for you but yeah I hope you appreciate
it and I'll see you in the next video
all right thank you for watching